[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد مزيما
لنستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
ولكن بايجاز هيا بنا
سجال وحرب اتهامات اشتعلت الاسبوع الماضي
بين واشنطن وموسكو اثراء اسقاط مقاتله
روسيه لمسيره امريكيه فوق مياه البحر
الاسود الولايات المتحده وصفت تصرف
الطائرات الروسيه بالمتهور بينما حضرت
موسكو من خطوره تطور هذه الحوادث الى
مواجهه نوويه وفي خطوه غير مسبوقه المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه اثرت امرا باعتقال بوتين
ومفاوضه حقوق الطفل في الكريم بتهم ارتكاب
جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي رحب بالقرار في حين
قللت موسكو من اهميته ووصفته بالمستفز اذا
قرار وصف بالتاريخ ولكن ما دلالاته فعليا
لنسال الدكتور بول مرقس استاذ القانون
الدولي
مرحبا دكتور
ما الذي يعني هذا القرار ومن الاخر هل
سيتم اعتقال بوتين
طبعا لهذا القرار دلالات كبرى رمزيه
معنويه مبدئيا يعني فائقه الاهميه لكن على
المستوى العملي فانه صعب التنفيذ يعني
لكنه يضع احراجا كبيرا امام الرئيس الروسي
في تنقلاته يعني طبعا قد ازعج الكثيرين
ممن يعني شابهوا هذه الوضعيه كرئيس
السوداني السابق عمر البشير عندما تنقل
بين الدول الافريقيه والعربيه لكن بالنسبه
لدوله عظمى ورئيس هذه الدوله لن يطوله
التنفيذ طبعا لكن سيكون محل ازعاج واحراج
كبيرين شكرا جزيلا لك
غموض يكتنف ما عرف بعمليه مجده حيث تدور
تساؤلات عما اذا كانت الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه ستشهد تصعيدا مع اعلان
اسرائيل قتل شخص قالت انه تسلل من لبنان
وفجر عبوه الناسفه عند مفترق مجد جنوب
حيفا حزب الله الصمت ولم يعلق على الحادثه
في حين نفذ قواته اليونيفال ملاحظتها عبور
اي شخص للحدود من جانب اخر شهد مخيم جنين
تصعيدا جديدا بعد اغتيال قوه اسرائيليه
خاصه اربعه فلسطينيين من بينهم قياديان
بسرايا القدس وكتائب القسام الازمه بين
الحكومه الباكستانيه وعمران خان تصاعدت
خلال الاسبوع الماضي حيث حاولت الشرطه
اعتقال خان ما ادى الى اشتباكات مع انصاره
كما اقتحمت الشرطه منزله بحجه تعرض
افرادها لاطلاق نار وبينما علقت محكمه
اسلام اباد العليا تنفيذ امر جلب بحقه
اتهم خان في مقابله مع الجزيره قائد الجيش
بالتامري لمنعه من المشاركه في الانتخابات
هل تذكرون الازمه الماليه عام 2008
المخاوف من حدوث ازمه مشابهه جديده عادت
بعد انهيار مصرف بنك سي
بسبب تهافت مفاجئ على السحب الودائع فهو
البنك المقرض الرئيسي للشركات الناشعه في
الولايات المتحده وهو ما دفع الرئيس بايدن
الى طمانه مواطنه بان نظامهم المصرفي امن
رغم الهلع الكبير الذي شهدته الاسواق
الماليه في العالميه والخوف من انتقال
العدوى الى البنوك الاخرى هذه الازمه القت
بالكثير من الاسئله اعلى منصات عالم المال
والاعمال وذلك في مختلف انحاء العالم فهل
يا ترى نحن امام ازمه ماليه جديده مماثله
لن اجد افضل من نديم الملاح ليجيبني على
هدف التساؤل مرحبا نديم اذا هل ستعود هذه
الازمه وستؤثر على اعداد كبيره من الدول
والاشخاص كما فعلت تلك التي كانت عام 2008
بما انك تقارنها ب 2800 لابد من مقارنه
العوامل المحيطه في الازمتين 2008 كانت
مرتبطه بازمه العقاريه الان هناك ليست
ازمه فقاعه موجوده في القطاع المالي
المصرفي مرتبطه
مؤسسه كبيره الان احجام البنوك صغيره
ومتوسطه نوعا ما سرعه
الاستجابه من السلطات الامريكيه بالتدخل
بضمان الودائع كانت اسرع من الخطوات التي
كانت في 2008 2008 الازمه حصلت في سبتمبر
التدخل كان في الشهر الذي في اواخر الشهر
الذي بعده جاءت نوعا ما متاخرا ربما هذه
السيطره والاداء الاقتصادي الجيد تحديدا
في الولايات المتحده بيانات البطاله قويه
ليست هناك احجام مديونيه كبيره مثل ماء
2008 فاعتقد ربما الدرس الذي تعلمناه من
2008 يمكن ان يخفف من حده هذه الازمه ولا
تنتقل او تبقى في حدود الولايات المتحده
والمؤسسات الصغيره والمت شكرا جزيلا لك
نديم الملاح الان الى موضوع اخر من
الاقتصاد الى السينما وموضوع متعلق بجوائز
الاوسكار اذ شهد الاسبوع الماضي التوزيع
جوائز الاوسكار في نسختها 95 وقد حصد فيلم
في انجاز نادر سبعه جوائز بينها افضل فيلم
وقد اخترت النجمه الماليزيه ميشيليو كافضل
ممثله وهي اول اسيويه تفوز بالعسكر فوز
الفيلم بهذا العدد الكبير من الجوائز اثار
جدلا وتساؤلات حول ما اذا كان يستحقها
فعلا التصويت كان والجوائز اخذها ولكن انا
معي الان خليل حنون وهو المختص في الفيلم
والسينما عندنا هنا في الجزيره ليساله
خليل هل بالفعل تعتقد بان الفيلم يستحق
هذا الفوز بهذا العدد الكبير من الجوائز
الانطباع العام كان بعد جوائز الاوسكار ان
هذا الفيلم لا يستحق هذا الكم من الجواز
المتوسط اذا اول ملف مشترك بين قارتين
بشكل رسمي لاستضافه كاس العالم في تاريخ
الفيفا برايكم ما هي حظوظ هذا الملف
المشترك في تنظيم الحدث العالمي شاركونا
ارائكم في التعليقات نلقاكم الاسبوع
المقبل في نشره جديده اينما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]